and talking about magnus scrolls and we
are now joined by magnus after a great
day of chess three wins for you magnus
uh are you happy with your performance
today
yeah it was okay actually i sort of felt
like i played
better yesterday and um
i have to say two of the game games i
won were
kind of gifts by by my opponents
um but no obviously the
the score is uh the score is great um
and it puts me puts me in a puts me in a
great position uh
i i just feel as though i have to play a
bit better in the knockout stages but
i'll worry more about that later i guess
well
but i mean yeah because you mentioned it
we have seen you just be fantastic in
all the preliminaries basically but can
you tell us something about your chest
form is it feeling
even better this time and than in the
last tournament
not particularly
as i sort of mentioned before the
tournament i'm just trying not to
well i'm basically not trying too much
i'm uh
playing playing some weird things in the
in the openings and just uh try to be
um be as casual as possible and just
just play chess and that is working
working well so so far but i don't
necessarily think it's gonna
it's gonna cut it and um the knockouts
and well uh i want to tell you mine is
so yesterday
uh 25 out of 40 games ended up with a
winner
and of course also a loser in round nine
today
seven out of n eight games ending up
with the winner and we know it is the
magnus carlsen invitational
so is it the magnus effect on all the
other players as well now
just a lot of games uh so exciting
i don't think it's on it's only it's
only me but
uh you love to see it that people are
are fighting like uh like like crazy
and uh uh it's been fun to watch the
other
other games as well because you can
really
you can really feel the the tension
and mistakes may some
sometimes appear sort of inexplicable
but they they
they appear because of because of
tension and it's been
it's been it's it's been a great show so
far um
not just to play but to works as well
and uh we're following now aneesh giri
and uh chakra
mamjara i don't know if you're you're
seeing the game but if you are
we would love your expert opinion
uh yeah so what speaks in uh
anish's uh favor here
is that there are um
there are two pairs of
uh rooks or yeah he has a rook and
a queen if you exchange either a rogue
or the queens i think
black would be um completely all right
but um in the current situation it feels
like
there's just a little bit too much
material on the board
and the rook on g6
is is kind of poor and with that much
material on the board i think
white has uh has good chances to either
drum up an attack or or um
or um something else um
i'm not sure i love bishop g3
maybe bishop d4 there was sort of more
incisive i don't know um
but but yes certainly this is not going
to be
not going to be easy for uh for
chocolatier now i think knight d4
wins uh wins upon at the very least
um so um it's looking
pretty pretty bright for promise to give
you here
um magnus earlier you mentioned you won
two games today from getting gifts from
your opponents did that include against
jan napoliacci we were following that
game we saw you
laughing shaking your head a bit of
everything there in that one
yeah it was a bit a bit of a shame
because i had a i had a good position
from the opening that i
um that i sort of misplayed and he
started
he started out playing me there and i
really was was on the ropes
and the the amazing thing about
his bishop sack is that i'd seen
beforehand
that that um
there were
there was there were two reputations
of of that move and because of that
i believe there was no chance he would
play it but
because one reputation you may miss
but you usually don't miss two so that's
why i consider
that an absolute gift um
since it's not not
the sort of thing that you should
usually should usually happen
maybe he thought he was uh winning
then realized it was not quite as clear
as
he thought and then got
got frustrated um
[Music]
but who knows it's interesting by the
way that now
i guess sanish will take on take on f7
b4 will happen and he will probably have
to exchange that
hans and exactly what i was talking
about earlier
um uh rooks remain
on on the board without the rocks it
would be a fairly straightforward draw
but with the rooks white should have
good winning chances
all right well magnus we love your eggs
for commentary thank you for joining us
and
and good luck tomorrow thank you uh i
will
like last time i said that
the seating didn't really matter um but
i mean there are tour points on stay
uh on uh what's
at stake uh and also picking colors
all the way through the knockouts is
really nice i'm gonna be
aiming pretty uh pretty hard for the
number one seed tomorrow
fantastic to hear all right well thank
you magnus
thank you